.
>> WE COACH BALL, WE DON'T LOOK
AT COLOR.
>> YOU ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
REPRESENTATION MATTERS TOO,
RIGHT?
YOUNG, ASPIRING COACHES OR
FOOTBALL PLAYERS, THEY SEE YOU
GUYS, THEY SEE SOMEONE THAT
LOOKS LIKE THEM, MAYBE GREW UP
LIKE THEM, THAT HAS TO MEAN
SOMETHING.
>> WHEN YOU SAY YOU GUYS AND
LOOK LIKE THEM MEANS THAT WE'RE
ODDBALLS TO BEGIN WITH, AND I
THINK THE MINUTE YOU GUYS STOP
MAKING A BIG DEAL ABOUT IT,
EVERYBODY ELSE WILL AS WELL.
JOEY: HERE TO REACT IS THE
FIREBRAND AT THE INTERSECTION OF
SPORTS AND POLITICS, CLAY
TRAVIS.
[LAUGHTER]
LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE HAVING FUN OUT
THERE.
>> HEY, WE ARE READY FOR AN
INCREDIBLE GAME HERE, UNIVERSITY
OF TENNESSEE IS BACK BIGTIME,
SHOWDOWN --
[LAUGHTER]
THIRD SATURDAY IN OCTOBER.
WE'LL GET TO THAT IN A MINUTE,
BUT, MAN, I ABSOLUTELY LOVED
THAT RESPONSE.
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
OUT THERE WATCHING RIGHT NOW
SAYING WAY TO GO, COACH, FOR
FIRING BACK.
LOOK, THIS IS WHAT'S UNFORTUNATE
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THIS IS AN
ESPN IF REPORTER LECTURING, A
WHITE WOMAN, BY THE WAY,
LECTURING A BLACK HEAD COACH
ABOUT WHY HIS RACE MATTERS SO
MUCH --
JOEY: YEAH.
>> -- IN A GAME WHERE, FRANKLY,
IF YOU'RE A STEELERS FAN OR
YOU'RE A BUCS FAN, ALL YOU CARE
ABOUT IS WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
IN THE GAME.
YOU DON'T CARE WHO'S ON THE
SIDELINE.
THIS THING WENT VIRAL.
I THINK 150,000 OR SO PEOPLE
LIKED IT, JUST FROM MY TWITTER
ACCOUNT ALONE, MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE HAVE WATCHED THAT CLIP.
AND I JUST AM SO PROUD OF HOW
WELL IT'S BEEN RECEIVED.
YOU KNOW THIS, TWITTER IS OFTEN
A LEFT-WING CESSPOOL, BUT I
THINK THAT RESPONSE JUST KIND OF
SOLIDIFIED WHAT'S SO GREAT ABOUT
SPORTS.
YOU GET JUDGED ON THE MERITS OF
YOUR PERFORMANCE FINISH JEE YEAH
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> IDENTITY POLITICS MIXED WITH
SPORTS HAS NEVER MADE SENSE, AND
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A PERFECT
ANSWER.
JOEY: IT WAS.
AND, YOU KNOW, AS A FALCONS FAN,
A RELUCTANT FALCONS FAN, I'M
LOOKING AT TAMPA BAY LIKE, I
DON'T KNOW, MAYBE I CAN CHEER
FOR THOSE GUYS AFTER THAT.
[LAUGHTER]
TALKING ABOUT SPORTS FANS, I'M A
GEORGIA BULLDOGS FAN, I KNOW WHO
YOU ARE IS AND WHERE YOU ARE.
TELL ME ABOUT TENNESSEE AND
ALABAMA.
>> LOOK, I MEAN, THIS IS ONE OF
THE BEST RIVALRIES IN ALL OF
COLLEGE FOOTBALL.
JOEY: YEAH.
>> I'VE GOT THREE KIDS THOUGH,
14, 12 AND 8.
THEY'VE NEVER BEEN ALIVE TO SEE
TENNESSEE BEAT ALABAMA.
NICK SABAN IS 15-0 AGAINST THE
UNIVERSITY OF TENNESSEE SINCE HE
CAME BACK TO ALABAMA.
IN ORDER TO TRULY GET OVER THE
HUMP AND ARGUE THAT TENNESSEE IS
BACK AND THAT THIS IS A RIVALRY
AGAIN, SOONER OR LATER
TENNESSEE'S GOING TO HAVE TO
BEAT NICK SABAN.
THIS IS THE BEST CHANCE THEY'VE
HAD IN YEARS.
TENNESSEE IS UNDEFEATED, 5-0,
GOING UP AGAINST AN UNDEFEATED
ALABAMA TEAM, FIRST TIME BOTH
TEAMS HAVE BEEN UNDEFEATED SINCE
1989 IN THIS STORIED RIVALRY.
PEOPLE ARE STARTING TO SHOW UP
FOR THE TAILGATE SCENE, OVER
100,000 PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
IN NEYLAND STADIUM BY 3:30
EASTERN, AND AS YOU WELL KNOW,
SEC FOOTBALL IS ELECTRIC, AND
THIS ATMOSPHERE IS GOING TO BE
THE BEST AND BIGGEST AND
BADDEST, I THINK, IN NEYLAND
STADIUM SINCE THE 1990s BY
KICKOFF.
JOEY: REAL QUICK, MY BULLDOGS
ARE 1-6 AGAINST NICK SABAN.
IT'S NOT EASY.
GOOD LUCK TO TENNESSEE TODAY.
GIVE ME AN UPSET, ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT CLEMSON/FSU?
YOU GOT AN UPSET REAL QUICK?
>> I LIKE TENNESSEE TO PULL OFF
THE YOU HAVE SET -- UPSET.
I THINK TENNESSEE GETS IT DONED
TODAY.
35-31, VOLS FINALLY GET A WIN
AGAINST NICK SABAN.
JOEY: RIGHT THERE FROM CLAY.
>> GET YOUR MONEY IN RIGHT NOW.
JOEY: DON'T FORGET TO CH